good morning belief nation today we're
going to talk about how you can be more
productive high performers just produce
more if you look at a high performing
athlete they're putting in more hours on
the field if you look at a high
performing executive they're more
efficient and effective with their time
than their counterparts it's just it
seems in the same amount of time they
get more done or they get in the
experience deeper or they're more
efficient and effective at it and
because they are obviously they're able
to get ahead faster than other people
but we have to look at that in our own
lives you know how productive have have
you been in this last couple weeks be
honest about it because it's gonna
dictate whether or not you're gonna ever
reach your full potential
is it true productivity has so much to
do with our full potential you look at
even an artist a lot of artists are
judged based on how prolific they were
were they productive in their careers
did they'd put out one painting or were
they like Monet whether they put out one
music you know one musical arrangement
or were they a Beethoven were they
thinking of one formula or were they
solving all formulas like Einstein
there's something about a high performer
in any area that they just get more done
partially because they stay at it
partially because of clarity energy and
courage so honestly evaluating ourselves
in that area is vital
so no matter how late at night you go
before you wrap up just take four
minutes and really think through
everything that you have to get done for
the next day so here's how I usually do
it first thing I do is I open up my
calendar and I take a look at all the
appointments that I have for the next
day and the time that those appointments
will take like this one o'clock I got a
team call that last 30 minutes 3:30 I
have a marietv script review that'll
take about an hour and then I have a
6:30 spin class then I write down all
the projects and the tasks that I need
to get done and I give myself a little
bit of an estimate about how long I
think each project or task will take of
course these are estimates sometimes I
get things done faster and sometimes
they take longer but at least I get
myself a baseline to work off of 9:00 to
10:30 a.m. I'm gonna write a first draft
of a sales video script I'm gonna give
myself about 90 minutes then from 11:30
to 12:30 I'm gonna review my social
media schedule give myself an hour for
that and from 2:30 to 3:00 I'll do a
little email clear-out
and finally I make a new little section
at the bottom of my notepad with
personal things that I need to handle
for that day for example get nanny a
birthday card and mail it that'll take
me about 30 minutes order more kuma food
all of 10 minutes and book a haircut for
the next month takes me about five
minutes boom that is it super simple so
when I do this it informs exactly when I
need to be at my desk and working which
tells me when I need to wake up to have
enough time to do my little morning
routine and get everything done without
feeling rushed or stressed the worst
thing you can do is wake up in the
morning and go straight to your computer
and open up email and then all of a
sudden you're pretending to work all day
and at the end of the day nothing
important ever got done nobody's perfect
and of course not every day goes as
planned but this system gives you the
best chance possible and making sure
that your most important projects get
done especially if you have an
inconsistent schedule the myth
the harder I work the more productive I
will be is has been debunked by the
science if you study human performance
just what they've realized and Jim lair
and Tony Schwartz have done some great
work in this field but here's what the
science says optimal performance and
productivity happens in 90-minute cycles
so what am I saying work for 90 minutes
and then take a break to recover then
will form not another 90 minutes and
then go for a walk and then work for
another 90 minutes and then take a drink
of water and then work for another 90
minutes and maybe take a nap or read
something interesting that's not related
to what you were doing what will that do
it will keep your mind focused on the
work at hand it will increase your
energy his Energy's like well you
deplete it you need to fill out the well
again and it will really keep you and
your productive s and also keep you
inspired rather than getting burned my
marketing activity for Wine Library was
productive because I grew my family
business to a big business it also
became the output of my learnings that
became the foundation of my personal
brand which became the beacon to
building the fastest growing social
digital agency ever right like so like
I'm always I'm doing things that people
feel are not scalable in the moment that
I find to be very scalable if you're
willing to look at them in a five to
10-year window got it like was it
productive for me to take that meeting
with Chris deci when he randomly emailed
me and said hey will you take this
meeting and I said sure which then led
to a 15-minute I'm just gonna pay
forward to this kid moment which I love
to do because you never know well in
this time I didn't know because it led
to he being one of the early employees
of Buddy Media which was a company Mike
Lazaro had and I will tell you that that
led to free office space at wine lot for
vaynermedia when we started it in the
conference room at Buddy Media it also
led to me giving a quote to Mike Lazaro
for a buddy media where he gave me
warrants to his company which later sold
for a billion dollars to Salesforce so I
made seven figures on a quote to a
website so I called that productive for
that 15-minute meeting but it also led
to a friendship that has become one of
the core friendships for Lizzie and I
and this Saturday night I got to spend
time
with a very small group for his oldest
son's Bar Mitzvah and that speech to the
son gave and the speech that Mike gave
is something that is engraved in my
heart for the rest of my life
I called that productive but then
there's a billion 15-minute meetings
that I take where the kids are piecing
and nothing good happened so when you
play it in a net-net game I think that
people are overthinking their at-bats
right and I think intent matters I think
people are trying to be too technically
sound to they're not allowing for
serendipity and serendipity is where all
the magic is my friends all of it and
when you think in terms of outcomes in
that activities pretty soon some of the
activities are you don't even need to do
to get the outcome you find a better way
to get the outcome quicker
now how do you do that yes three
questions question one what is my result
was my outcome what is that I really
truly want from this if you're going
back next week he said this next week
one of the most important what outcomes
for me to get this week in my business
he is right those outcomes are not your
action items the outcomes you if you do
that nothing else you'll be ahead of the
game and if you just keep looking those
outcomes every day how am i doing on
that outcome your brain will come up
with ways to get to that outcome I
promise you focus on the outcomes not on
activities action for most people
activities most people may mistake
movement for achievement they mistake
action items and to dues for achievement
we're after the achievement are you with
me on this yes or no it's a different
way of thinking and I think all of you
inherently have it but if you make this
ritualized
just like the things you've learned this
week they're all great but if you don't
systematize them they'll work when you
do them but if you systematize them
right and you see like mr. Holloman here
where he goes in and just does it and
does it make sure it's being done again
or what you've seen chat do or what I do
you just do it over and over again you
don't miss it now the results are
geometric so I'm gonna get you
systematize the thinking whether you do
it visually the way I'm gonna show you
or not so first question what's the
result of NAFTA what's the ultimate
result what I want out of this week out
of this thing out of my business
my life out for my body and you want to
be as what is possible when you describe
that outcome that result that's why as
clear and specific as possible
generalities will confuse you the 4-hour
workweek is possible but you need to
completely unplug and reset and the
reason that's necessary is because there
is an epidemic and I do mean epidemic in
this country of information abuse an
information addiction where people have
come to believe that checking email 200
times per day having a blackberry to
your head or in your hand while you're
at dinner or on the subway or in your
car or with your friends is the path to
becoming more productive and more
successful it isn't it isn't because
giving everyone around you every person
in the world immediate access to you is
inviting interruption and inviting
minutiae to completely invade your life
which is happening to everyone and it
did happen to me I had no intention of
writing this book but from 2000 to 2004
I was working at startups in Silicon
Valley I started my own I was CEO and I
worked from 7:00 a.m. to 9:00 p.m. every
day I checked Outlook hitting send
receive 100 to 200 times per day like a
rat with a cocaine pellet dispenser
slept under my cubicle sent emails on
Thanksgiving to prospects it was a
depressing scene and it's very
unfortunately common scene and I think
everyone is at a point of overwhelm
there is more information than we can
possibly organize time management is
dead the way turnaround is you have to
completely unplug and reset that means
you need to take a step back forget
about what people expect you to do
forget about what's popular and really
look at what works and what is consuming
your time so there are four steps
there's definition elimination
automation and liberation
definition is simple first need to
define your ideal lifestyle what do you
want to be doing from when you wake up
to when you go to sleep and so what do
you want to have what do you want to be
what you want to do and how much does
that ideal lifestyle cost and that big
your target elimination is simple it's
getting rid of everything all the static
all the noise all the interruptions of
the micromanaging all the people
possible that interfere with getting you
to that ideal lifestyle
the third automation is about taking the
few remaining tasks that are important
the time-consuming and either delegating
automating or somehow outsourcing them
so in my particular case I have an army
of MBAs in India about 25 of them who
work for $4 an hour and take care of
tasks that otherwise consume hundreds of
my hours and then the last step
liberation is about the final ingredient
in lifestyle design which is mobility
and then also how to use the time once
you create it which is very difficult
for most people okay this is fascinating
but that's the point it is difficult to
mean how do you put the BlackBerry down
how aren't you worried that you're not
gonna make as much money that you're
gonna lose clients do you have
statistics that show that that's not the
case
I have statistics that would absolutely
make your head spin so if you're
interrupted by email and phone there was
an experiment done at Kings King's
College for example to showed that
people who were stoned scored six points
better on an IQ test and people were
interrupted by email phone and that good
to know
26% of people in the American workforce
are on the verge of a nervous breakdown
the system is not working so it's not a
question of of if I should do this this
question of when it is the only real
alternative so one simple step then
people can take a baby step to prove the
concept is to simply use an
autoresponder set up an autoresponder
that tells everyone who emails you I
will be checking email twice a day at
11:00 and 4:00 p.m. if you require a
more urgent response before one of those
two times call me on my cell phone okay
if I start losing customers I'm gonna
call you too
you can call me okay what's going to
happen instead of losing customers
you'll get more done in the next 48
hours and you would in the next two
weeks thank you guys so much for
watching I made this video because then
su chio one asked me to so this is a
topic you'd like me to cover in the next
edition of belief life leave it in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I'd also love to know which of the
clips resonated with you
and why leave it in the comments and
will join the discussion thank you so
much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon